we had absolutely no idea what people
were going to do these things when we
started out matter of fact the two
people it was designed for was was in
myself because we couldn't afford to buy
it a computer kid on market
so we liberated some parts from Hewlett
Packard and Atari and worked on a design
for about six months and decided that we
would build it on computer so we built
and woz was up till 4:00 and morning for
many moons and we got it working we
showed some reference immediately
everybody wanted and it turned out to
take about 40 hours to build one of
these things and about another 20 30 40
to debug it and we had a lot of friends
and worked at similar companies who
could liberate the parts also we found
ourselves spending every spare moment of
our time helping our friends to build
computers and it was just getting to be
a tremendous drain on our on our lives
so we got the idea one day that that we
could make a printed circuit board
without the parts and it's le blank
printed circuit boards to our friends
and probably cut the assembly and debug
time down to you know 5 10 hours so woz
SOLAS HP 6 calculator and I sold my van
we got 1,300 bucks together man we pay
our friend of ours who was this PC board
layout person 1,300 bucks to do us a
layout and decided we'd sell printed
circuit boards at twice what it cost to
build him and hopefully recoup our
calculator and transportation assembly
today so that's what we did and I was
out trying to peddle PC boards one day
and walked into a bike shop the first
byte shopping Mountain View and Paul
Terrell then owner of the bike shop said
he would like to take 50 of these
computers and I saw dollar signs in
front
and but he had one catch which was that
he wanted them fully assembled and
tested ready to go which is a new twist
so we spent the next five days on the
phone at distributors and convinced the
electronics parts distributors around
here to give us about $10,000 worth of
parts on thin air
Kljestan enthusiasm so we got the parts
and we built 100 computers and we sold
50 of them for cash in 29 days paid off
the distributors and that's how we got
started so we had 50 computers left over
while that meant we had to sell so then
we started worrying about marketing
worrying about distribution got on the
phone of the other computer stores
around the country and gradually the
whole thing began to build momentum and
at that point in time we had some
feeling that we were on to something but
the feeling was so different than the
experience of actually seeing it happen
right now it's entirely different and
sometimes a lot of a lot of people ask
what did you know it was going to
mushroom into this phenomenon and you
can say yeah you know we planned it out
we had led on a piece of paper but
different than the experience is seeing
500 people working at Apple Computer
it's very different than the experience
of seeing a five-year-old kid who really
understands what he's the tool that he's
gotten from